cuando converso con mi padre respecto de
los cambios que ha sufrido la humanidad
en los últimos tiempos siempre
terminamos discutiendo de cuál de las
generaciones fue la que más impacto él
me habla de su relación con la radio con
la televisión y del hombre a la luna yo
le hablo del móvil de la internet de la
caída del muro
es importante porque porque si en algo
si estamos de acuerdo y espero que
ustedes lo compartan es que lo que
caracteriza nuestros tiempos son los
cambios y los cambios cada vez más
acelerados algunos ejemplos
a la radio le tomo 38 años en alcanzar
los 50 millones de clientes la
televisión 13 la internet en 4 años
alcanza ese objetivo el ipod vendió 50
millones unidades sólo en tres años el
facebook tuvo 50 millones de conexiones
a los dos años
saben hoy día me acordaba que el
facebook ya lleva 14 años con nosotros
14 y para nosotros los hispanoparlantes
es curioso no cómo pasa el tiempo
insisto si en algo estamos de acuerdo es
en esto en la velocidad con que
cambiamos las cosas y ese cambio esa
velocidad ha dejado a muchas
organizaciones luchando por tan solo
sobrevivir el éxito hoy día es cada día
más difícil aquí les muestro algunas
organizaciones que siguen alcanzado el
éxito
estas organizaciones tienen cosas en
común y yo los invito a preguntarse qué
cosas hicieron posible ese éxito
bueno fueron y cubrieron necesidades
insatisfechas
algunas de ellas explícitas pero muchas
de ellas tacitas que estaban ahí que
eran una necesidad real pero que no
habían descubierto que fueron capaces de
despertar fueron apoyadas por supuesto y
apalancadas por la tecnología nos
imaginamos un número y díaz en la
tecnología del internet sería posible un
xlix y la capacidad de procesamiento de
almacenamiento y la capacidad que tienen
las redes no verdad fue la tecnología a
la que van en la encuesta realidad se
suma aquello el hecho que rompieron
paradigmas como decía tener rompieron
las estructuras rompieron con aquellos
estándares se preguntaron cosas nuevas
se contestaron cosas nuevas la verdad
dejó de ser verdad del procedimiento
establecido dejó de ser procedimiento
establecido lo que los ayudó sí mucho
aquello es que no participaban del
negocio que interrumpieron
eso genera cambios y pusieron al hombre
en el último gran hito relevante de
estas organizaciones que pusieron al
cliente en el centro pero de verdad no
como marketing no como publicidad se
preocuparon de la verdadera necesidad
del cliente y fueron y la satisfacción
esa realidad la viven las organizaciones
esa realidad hizo que comience una
demanda por conocimiento y capacidades
que no existían
y esa realidad lleva a una
transformación que está muy de moda el
concepto transformación digital pero la
lleva a un lugar a la transformación del
trabajo
el negocio del trabajo también tiene su
propia transformación y no les voy a
hablar para no afectar a atenea de como
la inteligencia artificial van a
reemplazar al hombre les voy a hablar de
que hoy en día los diez puestos más
codiciados no existían hace diez años
les voy a hablar de que uno de cada
cuatro empleados
tiene menos de un año en la empresa que
está trabajando
les voy a hablar de que hay estudios que
plantean que al 2020 las personas de 40
años van a tener a lo menos 10 trabajos
distintos
les voy a hablar de que además tenemos
que hacer esfuerzo por preparar personas
para trabajar
en carreras en trabajos que hoy día no
existen con tecnologías que no se han
inventado y para solucionar problemas
que aún no se han creado no se han
descubierto entonces esa realidad en la
que tenemos que enfrentar y esa realidad
lamentablemente las organizaciones las
estructuras las instituciones de
educación superior no están dando
satisfacción de eso se dieron cuenta las
empresas tanto es así que ellas mismas
comenzaron a crear sus propias
universidades
todas esas organizaciones tienen su
propia universidad partieron con la
universidad de hamburguesas de
mcdonald's
pero hoy día general motors siemens y
muchas otras han ido cubriendo esa
necesidad primero para resolver una
necesidad que tenían sus propias
organizaciones conocimientos y
competencias para desarrollar el trabajo
en ella por supuesto su clima su cultura
pero rápidamente se dieron cuenta que
ese aporte no sólo servía para
satisfacer sus propias necesidades sino
también otras de la hora de la sociedad
y para introducir su propia forma de
hacer las cosas en la recta organización
incluso en la competencia
otra cosa que tuvo el efecto de esta
generación de universidades de empresas
es que empezó a presionar a las
instituciones de educación superior
tenían que flexibilizar su currículum
tenían que abrirse a la posibilidad de
que hubieran nuevas formas de entregar
eso nomás esos sistemas rígidos con
currícula fija
históricamente permanente aparecieron
aquellos que vendimos algunas canas
estos conceptos de ramos optativos
selectivos pero esas ramos fueron
tomando otra visión se fueron agrupando
y la demanda exigía que tuvieran una
representación una validez al exterior
aparecieron los mayores los minor
particularmente las universidades
americanas y nosotros latinos los
copiamos rápidamente pero en un
principio los minor fueron creados para
una especialización de la área del
conocimiento en el cual estaba de la
primera carrera
pero la demanda de médicos que sepan de
la nanotecnología la demanda de gente
que trabaje en energía que te va a
conocer medio ambiente y clima la
demanda de que agrónomos sepan de
genética hizo rápidamente que los magnos
derivarán a también cubrir otras áreas
del conocimiento
y aparecieron los college que también
era una respuesta a mayor flexibilidad y
los dejo con un aviso que aparece hoy
día en las paredes en las páginas web de
una institución de educación superior de
chile que habla de que el college te
permite ser el gestor de tu futuro
porque eso es lo que están demandando
hoy día los jóvenes para poder darse
facción precisamente a lo que las
empresas están demandantes déjame
construir a mí mi propio futuro
pero esa demanda no termina solo en
tener un currículum flexible porque eso
es como en la playlist poder armar de
una cantante las mejores canciones
lo que están demandando los jóvenes de
hoy día es que también pueda tener en
menos tiempo conocimiento en diferentes
expertos ese conocimiento y aparece en
universidades como la de ahora que como
la de microsoft que empiezan a dar rutas
de aprendizaje que pretenden resolver
problemas de gas
hoy día sacar un desarrollador un
analista dónde está assange en esas
organizaciones es importante
es fácil existe es corto se puede hacer
en el tiempo se puede partir desde niño
hoy día ya tenemos alumnos en básica y
media desarrollando programando haciendo
aportes a organizaciones eso está
pasando y días señores y esa realidad la
podemos usar
la podemos aprovechar
pero ese tiempo no sólo impacta por esas
organizaciones las universidades están
haciendo transformaciones también y es
así como por ejemplo en eeuu aparecen
los micro masters o micro maestrías
por supuesto les seguimos esas micro
maestrías permiten tener en este más
especializados masters a mucho menos
tiempo ya mucho menos costos
porque porque la demanda es esa
necesitamos aprender conforme a las
necesidades que el mercado me exige
conforme mis propios intereses conforme
a mi propia realidad a la cual quiero
enfrentar
la place lista la educación entonces
deberá ofrecer ciclos de aprendizaje en
la cantidad en la oportunidad y de la
fuente que el estudiante desee
esa es la forma en que enfrentaremos eso
hoy en día ya alumnos de base que media
de este país están abandonando el
formato tradicional estás tomando este
camino y están siendo recibidos por
universidades americanas también lo
están haciendo universidades españolas
eso es lo fascinante de esta nueva
opción quién va a tomar ese control
quién va a ser el spotify de que pueda
mezclar diferentes realidades diferentes
cursos diferentes unidades a su vez de
diferentes universidades tradicionales y
de empresas es lo que yo desafío
preguntar pero ya hay algunos brotes y
hay algunos brotes respecto de esta
realidad estas organizaciones que les
muestro acá
todas ellas manejan cursos online y son
el conglomerado de la agrupación de
muchos cursos de distintas
organizaciones y tienen el respaldo de
la emt de harvard de la universidad de
illinois la universidad de pensilvania
de la universidad autónoma de madrid del
monterrey del tecnológico de monterrey
entonces hoy día ya podemos armar
nuestra propia currícula y yo le
pregunto si es que hubiere si hay aquí
gerentes de informática o técnico de
informática cuando tú tengas un
currículo en tu mano de un desarrollador
formado en microsoft o de un
desarrollador forma una diversa
tradición al cual vas a elegir
entonces esas son las oportunidades que
se nos están presentando acá
la playlist a la educación quién será
ese spotify quiero terminar presentando
es un desafío
porque una de las cosas positivas de
este fenómeno del cambio en que ese
cambio al ser cada vez más acelerado nos
lleva a los contadores a cero nuevamente
y eso les da a ustedes jóvenes
oportunidades de partido cada vez
nuevamente
atrévanse y generen sus propios
currículos estén atento a las
necesidades y demandas complementen
permanentemente ese currículum
de hoy en adelante la educación no va a
ser sólo una etapa de tu vida tiene que
transformarse en algo permanente que te
permita empezar de nuevo de cero cada
vez con algunas bases con algunas
capacidades pero adaptando te y
aprendiendo las nuevas capacidades y
nuevas demandas
y esa oportunidad no sólo existe para
ustedes los jóvenes ya está funcionando
para los niños como les decían básica y
media pero también existe para los
adultos
e incluso para los seniors aquellos que
pensaron que ya la rueda había pasado
bueno el negocio de hoy en día el tiempo
del día el mundo de y del día te va a
dar oportunidades cada vez porque vamos
a partir la carrera de nuevo porque
vamos a empezar otra vez de cero porque
los cambios van a estar ahí
permanentemente y no se van a ir los
invito a tomar ese desafío los invito a
mantener la educación por siempre entre
nuestras realidades los invito a buscar
esa playlist los invito a formar esa
playlist a buscar los cantantes que
ustedes le interesen a buscar aquellos
que cubran vuestras necesidades
muchas gracias